get my inner revolution book yeah I
still think that definitely but we just
subvert it that we are we're under the
control of war mongers at the moment of
war criminals actually they are
controlling us and taking all the money
and taking all the energy and have
they've controlled the media propaganda
vehicle and so on they have turned it
into basically and so but what's they
are kind of desperate though because
they're doing that but they're not
getting anywhere and the people are
getting more and more sick of it and the
people or have been were fooled into it
and frightened into it in various ways
but I think that's kind of it's like
it's the darkness before the dawn there
I think the people will really refuse at
some point at this rate no because you
know the Cold War they were kind of
happy in the Cold War these criminal
people because they had a big enemy that
they could promote that they were afraid
of they were very unhappy at the end of
world war two because that we won so
therefore there was no need to always in
American history before that as gore
Vidal brilliantly says we always
demobilized but in 47 Truman and others
decided that they would create this
enemy in the Russians our former great
allies who helped us beat the Germans
actually in the Italian was really the
Russian we're a major factor and there
were our major allies and suddenly
turned them into the devil and they
threatened them with nuke our nuclear
weapons which then caused them to like
build up nuclear and then we could have
an arms race for them then make them an
enemy then have all these proxy wars and
the happy days for the military of 40
years of Cold War then finally it
stopped and they didn't know what to do
they're doing Bush won no more cold war
no more things they even Bush won had
the temerity the old warrior CIA guy
that he is to say we might have a peace
dividend and he's talking there to all
the poor people in America all the
people with no decent roads and schools
and train systems and all the horribly
deteriorated infrastructure that the
u.s. now is a victim of like a fourth
world country and but no there's no
peace dividend because the old Secretary
of Defense
you know darth cheney writes up a big
program for world conquest
and so everybody's our enemy suddenly
then so it's even better we will only
had the Russians more now suddenly
everybody's our enemy and it's got to
find some people okay Laura TAC Iraq
will attack that we're there we'll
conquer from Iraq to central Russia ah
you know and get all the oil you know I
mean ridiculous thing he wrote in 1991
which they've been doing now in 2000
with the poor the poorest son who's just
a party animal who just you know wants
to sniff coke and have fun and they just
put him up there and he's like going
like this and they don't his know what
he's doing he's leading the charge of
these complete World War two lunatics
who are criminals really basically
themselves their war criminals but my
point is that that the the incompetence
of their way of going about it shows how
desperate they are because the system
that they sit astride of is no longer
functional you know I mean it a hundred
years ago 200 years ago in the time of
imperialism close them you could win a
war and that's defined by von Clausewitz
the war theorist says meaning you not
don't just beat the enemy's army you
then make the enemies population do what
you want and you have a colonial empire
and they produce goods for you and they
do things for you because then you can
subdue them but nobody can subdue
anybody now they just don't get subdued
even as much you guys if we saw that in
Vietnam but you guys wearing silk black
little pajamas running around in pajamas
kicked us right out of their country
we were people were falling off the side
of ships in Dunellen Harbor falling off
helicopters and stuff but you guys in
pajamas